sie zählten zu den fortschrittlichsten
Bauwerken der Welt
mit das modernste was Ingenieurs und
Baukunst zu bieten haben
heute sind sie morgen verwittert
manchmal sogar gefährlich
[Musik]
Brücken sind imposante Bauwerke und
architektonische Meisterleistungen sie
überspannen breite Taylor und Tiefe
aktuar.de
die Colorado Wüste in Kalifornien hier
sind die Tage eines verborgenen
Glanzstück der Konstrukteurs Technik
gezählt
[Musik]
die einmal höchste Brücke der Welt wie
innerhalb einer Minute einstürzte
im Grunde wurde sie vom Wind angehoben
und herum gewirbelt
[Musik]
im Süden
die riesige Holzkonstruktion ist keine
gewöhnliche Eisenbahnbrücke sie verläuft
in einer mächtigen Kurve und ist die
größte ihrer Art
[Musik]
bei Tagesanbruch macht sich ein Team vom
Southwest railway Mission auf dem Weg
zur Brücke
[Musik]
die Historiker wegen 25 km auf einer
Strecke zurück die für den normalen
Verkehr längst gesperrt ist
[Musik]
noch trotz die Brücke dem Zahn der Zeit
doch ihre Tage sind gezählt
[Musik]
unifac the Grand Canyon Canyon ist
einfach atemberaubend sie ist ein sehr
komplexes Bauwerk
in den USA
[Musik]
die Männer sollen die Bahnlinie
reparieren di San Diego mit dem Rest der
USA verbindet ein Tunnel ist bei einem
Erdbeben eingestürzt und soll so schnell
wie möglich durch eine gigantische Bock
Brücke ersetzt werden
der Jana Hayat ist die Leiterin des
Pacific Southwest railway Museum mit der
Bahnstrecke und ihrem Erbauer kennt sie
sich bestens aus
alles begann die
er war der Meinung San Diego brauche
genauso wie der Norden Kaliforniens eine
Bahnverbindung zum Osten des Landes
er war sicher dass die Hafenstadt davon
wirtschaftlich profitieren würde
brauchen Sie ein Beförderungsmittel das
bequem und vor allem preiswert ist
[Musik]
arbeitet
nur noch von der unmöglichen Eisenbahn
sie führt durch eines der
herausforderndsten Gebiete Nordamerikas
wie Muskat um Geld zu sparen kamen sie
auf die Idee einen Umweg über Mexiko zu
machen so konnten sie einige der
höchsten Berge umgehen die Strecke führt
70 km nach Süden und kommt erst bei
Linda wieder auf US Gebiet
sie führt weiter durch die Curry-Sauce
Schlucht den anspruchsvollsten Teil der
Strecke
[Musik]
da enttäuscht Rachel bis an die auf der
gesamten Strecke konnte die Erde
jederzeit nachgeben der Untergrund war
nicht stabil sie bauten auf lockerem
Granit Geröll und
standen sicher konstant unter Strom
geschafft haben ist unglaublich
[Musik]
beinahe die Bahnstrecke kostete ihn 18
Millionen Dollar danach war er so gut
wie pleite
[Musik]
Ingenieur dan Davis von den
Verkehrsbetrieben in San Diego hat sich
mit der Geschichte der unmöglichen
Bahnstrecke befasst
der wohnen
die schnellste und günstigste Lösung die
Tasse wieder instand zu setzen
wir links sehen Sie den eingestürzten
Tunnel 15
Kräfte gegeben
[Musik]
oder entsprach Sie einfach dem Zeitgeist
der da lautete es ist zwar unmöglich
aber wir schaffen es trotzdem
[Musik]
kein
Albtraum gewesen sein wir sind mitten in
der Wüste es gibt kein Wasser es ist
extrem heiß und das Bauholz ist
ansprechend oder
eine achtlos weggeworfene Zigarette
genügen um alles in Brand zu setzen die
herrschen furchtbare Bedingungen und
trotzdem haben sie es geschafft
Holz aber gerät leicht in Brand
Buschfeuer die in der großen Hitze
häufig entstehen sind ebenso ein Risiko
wie die Dampflok selbst
dafür allerdings finden die
Konstrukteure eine Lösung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
na gut hab wir wussten am Wassertank war
immer besetzt wenn ein Zug über die
Brücke fuhr öffnete er das Ventil und
setzte eine Beregnungsanlage in Gang so
wurde verhindert das heiße Metallteile
ein Feuer auslösten andernfalls hätte
höchste Gefahr bestanden
[Musik]
die Stabilität ist aber auch aus einem
ganz anderen Grund
die Brücke von
knapp 20 km
Imbiss deutsches Volk begeistern wie die
Gott kein Interesse sind ziemlich
beweglich wenn ein großer Zug darüber
rumpelte bewegten sich die Bauteile
Elemente Streben und Verbindungsstücke
mit das war genau so beabsichtigt es
gehört zu Schönheit solche Brücken die
Bewegung sorgt dafür dass ich die Last
auf die ganze Brücke verteilt und nicht
nur auf eine Stelle einwirkt
[Musik]
chopstick imposanten Brücke am goat
Canyon ist die ganze Bahnlinie nicht
allzu lange in Betrieb
[Musik]
die Verbindung zwischen San Diego und
Yuma Arizona als langsam schmutzig und
unangenehm die Wagen waren nicht
belüftet es gab keinen Sonnenschutz an
den Fenstern und in den Tunnels zogen
Dampf und Rauch in die Abteile die
Fahrgäste mussten die Fenster schließen
und bei 40 Grad schwitzen angenehm war
dass sich ja nicht
in guten Jahren arbeitet die Bahnstrecke
vielleicht kostendeckend in schlechten
machte sie Verluste nachdem 1976 der
Hurricane Kaeslin den Landstrich
verwüstet und dabei einigen Brücken und
Gleisen den Rest gegeben hatte war auf
die Southern Pacific schließlich das
Handtuch
an ihren trezor Bridge liegt so
versteckt dass nur sehr entschlossen der
Sandra bis zu ihr vordringen
aber auch mitten in Europa gibt es eine
Brücke aus den 30er Jahren des vorigen
Jahrhunderts die kaum jemand kennt
sie verschwindet fast komplett in einem
Stausee dabei zählt sie eins zu den
fortschrittlichsten Konstruktionen ihrer
Zeit
die borovsko Brücke im Volksmund auch
hitlerbrücke genannt
[Musik]
Corinna Million sie müssen sich die
etlichen Kubikmeter Wasser wegdenken
jetzt ist natürlich nichts davon zu
sehen es ist ein verborgenes Juwel
[Musik]
mit dem Einmarsch ins Sudetenland
beginnen die Truppen Adolf Hitlers die
Tschechoslowakei zu besetzen
vordergründig
zu holen
alle großen deutschen Städte
7 Monate nach Beginn der
Autobahn zwischen
[Musik]
sie besteht aus einem einzigen Bogen und
soll jede Menge Fahrzeuge tragen können
wenn du wusstest Rage Badesee Brücke an
sich war gerade aber bald gleich danach
eine Kurve kommen sollte ist sie leicht
nach rechts geneigt Zeit
[Musik]
konzipiert war sie für eine
Höchstgeschwindigkeit von 160
Stundenkilometern und die Kräfte
auszugleichen die auf die Fahrzeuge
einwirken muss sie der Autobahnbrücke
ein wenig schief sein nein mit dem
Untergrund hat das nichts zu tun
[Musik]
Joeys Andalusier moldes Autobahn geht
los war und Hitlers Autobahnen nicht nur
dazu da um von A nach B zu kommen
es ging um Nationalstolz es ging darum
die Welt zu beeindrucken und zur
führenden Weltmacht zu werden
also vor allem um Dominanz
bis 1943
in Berufskolleg sende Ingenieure
modernste Technik ein es mangelt ihnen
allerdings an Arbeitskräften
Gerätschaften und sogar Anbieter
[Musik]
im Juni 1941 marschiert Hitler in die
Sowjetunion
in der Tschechoslowakei und alle
öffentlichen Arbeiten außer an der
borovsko Brücke der eigentlich für
Straßen und Brückenbau vorgesehene Beton
wird jetzt für Abwehr Stellungen
benötigt
seine Luftschutzbunker mag Hitler von
Hulk verhungerten Zwangsarbeitern bauen
lassen für die Fertigstellung der
Borowski Brücke aber braucht er auch
weiterhin die tschechischen Ingenieure
[Musik]
dann im März 1942 wird Reinhard Heydrich
reichsprotektor für Böhmen und Mähren
und Cheforganisator des Holocaust bei
einem Attentat getötet
Mitarbeiter der Anschlag zeigte den
Nazis dass sie weder unbesiegbar noch
unverwundbar waren
[Musik]
ich zu stellen eine Verbindung nach
Westen wird nicht mehr gebraucht
[Musik]
1963 beschließt die Regierung unterhalb
der Brücke eine Talsperre anzulegen sie
soll den Großraum Prag mit Trinkwasser
versorgen so versinkt die Brücke die das
Land eins mit dem Deutschen Reich
verbinden sollte schließlich in den
Fluten
[Musik]
springen wir über den Atlantik zurück in
die USA die nicht mit dem Auto sondern
per Eisenbahn erschlossen werden
[Musik]
mehr als ein Jahrhundert lang steht im
Tal des ginsua River in Pennsylvania
einer Eisenbahnbrücke die als Triumph
amerikanischer Konstrukteurs Kunst Geld
die kinderbrücke ist zum Zeitpunkt ihrer
Fertigstellung die höchste Brücke der
Welt
erst im Jahr 2003 offenbart ein
verheerender Tornado einen Schwachpunkt
des majestätischen Bous
[Musik]
und 92 Meter hoch zwei Jahre lang ist
sie die höchste Brücke der Welt
Güterzüge mit Kohle für den Mittleren
Westen sollen über sie hinweg wollen
aber ist sie auch sicher
[Musik]
es
funktioniert
[Musik]
die Strecke sollte möglichst gerade und
eben sein wo wir ein Hindernis nicht
abtragen können die
[Musik]
anderen können
[Applaus]
laut Hersteller der Phoenix Bridge
company könnten die neuartigen Pfeiler
eine 300 m hohe Brücke tragen
[Musik]
lassen Sie sich nicht von der
ursprünglichen
[Musik]
bald stellt sich heraus dass die Züge
die Pfeiler so sehr zum Schwingen
bringen dass sie fortan nicht schneller
als mit 8 Stundenkilometern über die
Brücke fahren dürfen
bleibt die Frage ob sich dabei
stabilisieren lässt
über die Brücke wurde in erster Linie
Kohle transportiert
Industrialisierung Wirtschaft und Handel
nachholen
in which different Eisen ändert seine
Eigenschaften je nach Menge des
Kohlenstoffgehalt Gusseisen etwa =
zerbrechlich wie ein Butterkeks dass ich
einfach durchbrechen lässt
Schmiedeeisen ist dagegen eher wie ein
saftiger schokoladenkeks den man
auseinander ziehen kann
Stahl ist irgendwas dazwischen between
durchgeführte
sonnenschmiede Eisen und Stahl werden
aus Eisenerz gewonnen der Unterschied
ergibt sich aus dem
Herstellungsverfahren
Schmiedeeisen ist grundsätzlich ein sehr
einfacher Werkstoff unter dem Mikroskop
ist seine Oberfläche körnig und uneben
noch dazu ist es brüchig und lässt sich
nicht biegen Stahl dagegen hat eine
regelmäßige Struktur Stahl lässt sich
biegen und man muss sich schon mächtig
ins Zeug legen bis er letztlich nachgibt
und bricht
Schnaps
[Musik]
im Jahr 1900 werden die alten
eisenpfeiler abgerissen und durch ein
neues Stahlgerüst ersetzt
7 Jahre später kommen beim Einsturz
einer kanadischen Brücke der Phoenix
Bridge company
75 Arbeiter ums Leben es war also
offenbar richtig die eisenpfeiler der
kinzua Brücke auszutauschen
leider wurde bei der Sanierung
ordentlich gepusht
[Musik]
ersetzen aber nicht nur Schmiedeeisen
durch Stahl es gab weitere
Verbesserungen
1902 brachten sie an den Sockeln einiger
Pfeile auf der Ostseite kleine
Rollenlager an um die Brücke etwas
flexibler zu machen gerade so dass der
Wind den Pfeilern Streben und
fundamentanker weniger anhaben konnte
[Musik]
dadurch haben wir jetzt aber eiserne
Ankerbolzen am Fundament die nicht
ansatzweise lang genug waren um die neue
Stahlbrücke mit dem Fundament zu
verbinden also Verband man Eisen und
Stahl Teile einfach mit einem kleinen
Profil Stück
50 Volt 0 Jahre Plastiken zur Brücke in
Betrieb dann sind die Kohlevorkommen in
der Umgebung erschöpft
1959 vier letzte planmäßige Zug über die
Brücke 4 Jahre später wird sie zur
historischen Sehenswürdigkeit erklärt
in den 60er Jahren war es höchst
ungewöhnlich aus einer
heruntergekommenen alten Bahnstrecke
eine Touristenattraktion zu machen das
war was ganz neues
[Musik]
2003 wird die Brücke zu Sanierungs
Zwecken gesperrt
am 21 July unterbricht ein aufziehendes
Unwetter die Arbeiten aber es ist kein
gewöhnlicher Sturm
um 15:15 Uhr erfasst ein ausgewachsener
Tornado die Ostseite der Brücke
mit einer Geschwindigkeit von über 150
Stundenkilometern reißt er die
Stahlpfeiler aus der Verankerung
sie hat diese Brote die schmiedeeisernen
Ankerbolzen waren nicht lang genug um
das Stahlgerüst zu halten als der Wind
die Brücke anhob war das nachträglich
eingesetzte Profil Stück einfach zu
schwach
[Musik]
zerstört
die zuständigen Stellen entscheiden sich
gegen den Abriss der Brücke sie
beschließen alles genau so zu belassen
wie es ist
auf der Aussichtsplattform können sich
die Besucher von der schieren Kraft der
Naturgewalten überzeugen
[Musik]
ein Tornado zerstört die kinzua Brücke
in Pennsylvania im südafrikanischen
Kapstadt fällt eine Brücke ganz anderen
Problemen zum Opfer
[Musik]
nach fast 30 jähriger Anlaufzeit soll in
den 70er Jahren endlich eine Hochstraße
Namensforschung Freeway gebaut werden
doch am Ende steht doch nur eine
unsichtbare Brücke
im 25 Jahrhundert ist Kapstadt eine der
wichtigsten Hafenstädte Südafrikas doch
wie soll der Hafen mit dem Rest der
Stadt verbunden werden
[Musik]
Gieseking ist Soziologin mit dem
Fachgebiet Straßenbau sie hat sich
Schlange mit der komplexen Geschichte
der unsichtbaren Brücke beschäftigt
[Musik]
auf
der
Innenstadt
das 200 Hektar große Gebiet heißt
Vorschau und wurde komplett zu dem Meer
abgerungen
um es an die Stadt anzubinden werden
neue Straßen gebraucht damit fängt das
Problem an
die Hafenbehörde hat etwas sehr viel
nüchterne Riss im Sinn eine funktionale
Straßenführung für den Verkehr
[Musik]
History The Rock Geschichte kennt
unzählige Beispiele aus dem Bauwesen die
letztlich ein Kompromiss zwischen Form
und Funktion sind
dann meist ziemlich langweilig oder
enorm aufwendig da haben so viele Leute
der Finger im Spiel dass am Ende nie ein
einzelner die Entscheidungen trifft
endlich ist die Entscheidung gefallen
the reason why the freeway with the way
home jemand wusste warum die
Stadtautobahn so und nicht anders
konzipiert worden war dahinter stecken
die Lobbyisten der US-Autoindustrie und
zwar nicht nur in Kapstadt sondern auf
der ganzen Welt breite Schnellstraßen
für breite Buick Service große
amerikanische Straßenkreuzer
[Musik]
auf die große Politik beginnt sich auf
das Projekt Vorschau Freeway auszuwerten
die Apartheid Gesetze führen zur Räumung
des ethnisch gemischten Stadtteils
district 6
[Musik]
eigentlich fehlen nur noch wenige
Verbindungsstücke
noch Anfang der 70er Jahre werden die
Bauarbeiten gestoppt
[Musik]
es kursieren verschiedene Theorien
darüber warum die Schnellstraße bis
heute buchstäblich in der Luft hängt
eine besagt dass ein Händler dessen
Laden der Brücke im Weg war sich
weigerte zu verkaufen
laut meiner Lieblings Theorien
Planungsingenieur fest dass die beiden
Enden der Brücke sich gar nicht
verbinden ließen
Simon ibrains löchinger death is never
gonna happen
trotzdem warten die beiden Enden des
Vorschau Freeway immer noch darauf rein
zu werden
[Musik]
wenigstens lässt sich das Millionengrab
ab und zu zweckentfremden
[Musik]
viele halten sich für einen Schandfleck
aber für mich steht sie für die Kämpfe
die Kapstadt und ganz Südafrika
ausgefochten haben
[Musik]
die Borowski Brücke wurde nie
fertiggestellt und wird auch nie genutzt
werden aber nachdem sich jahrelang
niemand für sie interessierte erkennen
Ingenieure und Historiker allmählich
ihre Bedeutung für die
Ingenieurswissenschaften und die
Geschichtsbücher
[Musik]
Hitlers Brückenprojekt ist ein ethisches
Symbol für die Technologie der Nazis
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Brücke hat mehr zu bieten als nur
eine tolle Aussicht
[Musik]
dort gibt es etwas Bemerkenswertes zu
spüren zu erfahren für Ingenieure ist
sie eine Studie für die Zukunft lernen
können wenn du schon Eisen durch Stahl
ersetzt dann mach es auch komplett
anders sturbridge ist dekorieren für
Touristen so gut wie unerreichbar
ihre morschen Balken könnten jederzeit
von einem Jena Erdbeben zerstört werden
die Südkalifornien regelmäßig
erschüttern
über diese alten Brücken rollt
vielleicht kein Verkehr mehr aber als
beeindruckende Bauwerke können Sie uns
immer noch in andere Zeiten und Welten
bringen
[Musik]